man last night was good it was good even
though it was two ugly damn teams i'll
tell you that much i mean it really was
but uh nonetheless there's a lot to
discuss about the football game the jets
being the jets
looks like the game's there for them to
be had
and new england and cam newton cam
newton
played his best game as a pocket
quarterback
with the with the new england patriots
to this point and i know we had that
game in seattle but it was pretty damn
impressive what he did last night they
grinded it out and really
i mean they almost had to play perfect
to beat the jets
are we hearing that am i hearing that
right as somebody on my mouth new
england had to almost play perfect
to beat the new york jets who are the
worst team we've ever seen in the
history of the sport or you know in that
discussion but uh good for cam newton
and the new england patriots
i don't know if you had your coffee
earlier than usual today or there are
residual effects of some sort of
medication you took last night that made
you happier than usual you sound like
you're excited about the game last night
it didn't bother me it was good i mean i
knew i wasn't looking at two super bowl
champions that's for sure but i looked
at you know one team desperate adam gase
feel like he's looking you know into the
barrel of like whoa i might be fired if
we mess this up and i don't know what
happens i mean that that wasn't the best
look for them all together
but
new england under a different kind of
pressure cam newton under a different
kind of pressure everything like that
i did enjoy the football game i did and
you know i think there's a lot of
aspects to break down yeah it wasn't
pretty and beautiful but it's still
delivered and was not bad for monday
night football wow you thought it was
that bad i mean you you let's let's just
let's just paint with a broad brush give
me your dominant overriding emotion as
you were watching the three hours of
football that played out last night my
dominant overriding emotion was that
somewhere in the second quarter the new
england patriots realize that they're no
longer the mystique of the new england
patriots and they're not a good team i
feel like it hit them during the game
where they were like whoa all right the
jets are
you know we're not playing bad and
they're just beating us like i i that
was the first thing i think that jumped
out to me more than anything and then
just how hard it is for the new england
patriots to move the football i think
that would be the other thing and how
hard they have to work and mcdaniels and
belichick have to manage the game and
cam newton has to play i mean like we
saw you know other than not being a
little aggressive in the first half i
think he let let like let the jets off
the hook with some down the field
completions and checked it down
i mean he played really good and there
they were
he had to bring them back you know down
10 points and you know the start of the
fourth quarter
yeah look that was more specific than
what i was hoping for i
i i had just a sense of resignation the
whole time like okay it's monday night
football it's on tv it's my job there
are far worse jobs i don't take it for
granted but this is just one of those
games where i don't even know that if
when the schedule came out in april you
look at it and say hey that's a decent
game because it's still the jets right
it's a good rivalry or it's had its
moments nobody was really expecting
anything this year but uh you know look
it was still entertaining
and it is
weird
it's fascinating in a weird way
to see the patriots try to operate
successfully when they're so
much less than what they used to be
and
you
you almost feel bad for them and then
you remind yourself wait a minute
they're the patriots they've got six
super bowl trophies since 2001. i don't
feel bad for them welcome to how it
feels to be any other team in the nfl
you will have years where you stink and
i think the fact that we even pause
you know it's just something's not right
it's not right to have football season
with the patriots kind of pedestrian so
i was just kind of in this weird yeah
you know and you know there's no
consequence here i i yeah the patriots
in my preseason pick to get to the super
bowl and i don't abandon them until
they're mathematically eliminated but
that team that played last night even
though they won is not getting to the
super bowl chris you agree with me on
that yeah no there's no way i mean right
now the way it looks it'll be a miracle
if they get into the playoffs i mean
it's
every game is going to be tough and
close as you could see you know yeah
there's no stefan gilmore out there but
let's hit the defensive flaws you know
continually through the game i was
texting you and the group i mean i know
a few times where hey you know you see
all these one-on-one balls joe flacco
looked great last night yeah new
england's got no choice they got to put
all their corners on the island every
play they got no nobody no talent in the
front seven their best player lawrence
guy he wasn't playing i mean they got
nothing there so belichick and belichick
they gotta find nine million different
ways to put people out the line of
scrimmage to scare away you know frank
gore and the jets uh run game and all
those things i mean so they got issues
on that side of the ball certainly you
know they need stefan gilmore but
there's no big talent and then the
offensive side of the ball come on i
mean what what is there there's not
really an explosive running back there's
some solid running backs there's no
explosive wide receiver
i mean there's no tight end at all
basically in their game
it is cam newton having to drop back be
a man in the pocket and throw lasers to
guys that we've never heard of i mean
that's really what new england is and
you know for that that's where i give
cam newton a lot of credit that was a
pressure game for him i mean all the
pressure was on the patriots they were
supposed to win even though they're not
that much better than the new york jets
as we saw last night and cam newton for
where he is in his career
that was a really big game for him too
and i think with all that that was on
the line and everything mike and then
the fact that they changed the offense
you know this was the first game we saw
they said screw the cam newton shotgun
with bills and wessel whistles guys
going in speed motion and doing all that
they got into get underneath the center
drop back to pass here's a handoff play
action pass it was really a traditional
i formation offense and he handled it
well but man mike yeah they're they're
just they're not talented
i need to get a ruling from the control
room as to whether or not you've
expanded the simsism's book by saying
bills and wessels that may have
completed bills and websites i know that
you started with bills you started with
bills i don't think you quite got out
wessels but bills and wessels
i know that one that one you passed okay
control room tells me you're getting a
pass on that one uh here's here's bill
belichick talking about how his
quarterback performed in last night's
victory
dan did a great job he hung in there he
made some good reads and
they you know some good good adjustments
good checks uh that
um you know jets
great did a good job like they always do
put a lot of pressure um
in their
in their
defensive packages and
so he
can't do a nice job with it
got the decision some of these guys make
for how they sit and how they position
the camera
[Laughter]
he's like popping his head out of a hole
he doesn't care
no no he never cares cam newton was good
last night a couple of rushing
touchdowns 27 for 35 274 passing yards
no touchdowns but no picks 99 passer
rating and jacoby myers holy crap
targeted 14 times by cam newton 12
catches 169 yards
uh and k you know look cam
has had a rough year
i i believe that the covet 19
diagnosis affected him in a variety of
ways one the fact that he allowed
himself to get it the fact that he even
could get it so many of these guys think
they're impervious to it remember odell
beckham jr kind of joked about it
earlier this year but i think a lot of
those guys believe i'm not catching it
it's not affecting me and and i think
he's finally starting to maybe come out
of it you know they were concerned about
his decision making last night good
decisions what not a lot you know not
the kind of head-scratching stuff that
cost them games down uh the the past
month or so and uh you know he look he
looked like the guy
that i think the panthers had hoped he
would become as you said throwing from
the pocket at some point you have to
adjust your game if you want to play
deep into your 30s you can't run steve
young did that steve mcnair did that yep
um you know aaron rodgers still moves a
little bit but not like he used to you
got to operate from the pocket if you
want to continue to play deep into your
30s because at some point all those guys
you used to be faster than are now as
fast if not faster than you and they hit
you and they hurt you so uh this is what
we need to see more from cam and i think
for cam
it's about laying the foundation for
next year yeah whether he's in new
england or somewhere else this is
for the balance of the season his chance
to get people to say this is one of the
guys we need to put near the top of the
list as we evaluate quarterbacks yeah i
mean agreed he's that's that's what
that's what i mean when he's fighting
for his career i mean he's fighting to
be a starter next year whether that's
new england or somewhere else but just
to be looked at in that in that way once
again you know you there's a lot of
things to bring up you're right i mean
with cam newton hey first thing is
pocket passing i don't really care who
you are whoever it is i mean we talk
about lamar jackson at some point you're
going to play some defense that's going
to be able to contain your running and
in this league you're going to have to
make some throws within the general area
of the pocket to beat people i mean
that's what that's what it comes down to
cam newton showed that last night but i
think the big the big thing too is
you know we're seeing a guy and we heard
through the telecast and i think brian
griese brought it up at one point we're
just talking about and cam then admitted
it talking about how yeah early in the
year
you know he was running the offense and
doing things and all of that
but
he didn't really understand the offense
and for me
i'll take it like this he understood his
package of plays he didn't really
understand the language of the offense
and how it was orchestrated and i think
that's what you know that we were trying
to get across in the telecast last night
too that hurt his development and he had
to get further along in that area as far
as you know all the brain gymnastics and
that new england offense it's
complicated it really is and i think
that was some of the struggles and that
was the worst part about covet 19 mike
let me ask you a question yeah go ahead
yeah
does the fact that he's starting to
figure it out make him more likely to
stick around i i it's like i've put in
all this time
i've gone through these struggles i'm
starting to get it now next year will be
even better and i don't want to go
somewhere else and have to do this crap
all over i think so and i think if he
can continue to crack away you start to
see the genius of the offense you know
this is they're in elementary new
england offense they're not running tom
brady year 17 you know advanced geometry
and and just picking people apart no
they don't have the players to do that
they're too young they don't even know
all the rules within that offense yet so
yeah i think that if he can continue to
stay on this path he'll start to realize
wait they they can fit an offense around
me really well here and man you know
this offense whoa they they
deliver me some some very easy
completions and people open so i do
think that that hopefully the foundation
can be laid there last you know from
what we saw last night definitely i mean
hey what he did in the pocket we saw it
wasn't a ton of separation from any of
the receivers none of those receivers
are threatening anybody deep down the
field here the sprite chart you look at
it i mean
a lot of short passes the deep passes
are all around 15 16 20 21 25 yards is
the farthest completion of the night you
know he played smart i felt like he felt
the pressure in the first half of the
football game i really do
you know and i and i know mike at one
time i thought i'd text you maybe it was
you know the producers or whatever
but greasy mentioned it again to start
the second half and i wish he had showed
the replay saying you know cam didn't
push the ball in the first half and do
any of that and that was you know again
we're watching it on tv but there was a
few plays where i went oh man just stand
there you know the end zone cut i mean
there's a guy open blah blah blah and he
checked it down and to me that was him
you know protecting himself not wanting
to make the big mistake trying to run
the offense to a degree it was probably
moving a little fast and crazy for him
because it was different for him uh but
either way he adjusted and as you saw in
the biggest moments he made some big
time throws to help them win the game
you know one of the realities of
learning an offense is the defense is
going to try to create confusion and
force you to make decisions if you have
been making mistakes there's even more
of a temptation to do that he faced a
blitz 60 percent of the time on drop
backs that's the second highest by a
quarterback
all season long uh in the entire league
and teams are blitzing the patriots 44
of the time cam is the only quarterback
facing the blitz more than 40 percent of
the time so if you're making mistakes if
you're learning an offense that's the
best way to disrupt you because that's
when your brain short circuits if you
don't know what to do
and you have to make a quick decision
and here comes the blitz and accelerates
your process you're more likely to make
a mistake so you know maybe after a game
last night do do teams
take a step back and say
maybe we shouldn't do this yeah if if
he's if he's now starting to figure out
where his reads are and what he needs to
do when he gets blitzed and he's eluding
it and he's going to beat us do you
think that this influences teams to
maybe back off after seeing what
happened last night they might i think
it might make them think twice a little
bit yes but i don't think it's going to
totally influence them because the blitz
it works i mean
there's logic to why you do it against
cam newton the first thing is people
blitz because they go hey let's get
pressure on them yeah okay we're a
little compromised in the back end but
none of these guys are scary we we can
man them up in blitz or we can blitz and
play zone and be aggressive behind it so
there's that factor that emboldens teams
to blitz the other factor is hey let's
try to clog up lane so cam can't run
around and do something like that and
shoot a gap and scramble for 15 or 20
yards
uh and he is known to sit there in the
pocket at times for a long time
but i think with what we saw last night
him knowing where to go with the ball
you know didn't take any bad sacks that
i can really remember where i went oh
that was stupid he got the ball out of
his hands in those situations
and yeah that he was pretty on target
throwing the ball the rest of the night
yeah i think that could scare teams to a
degree to a degree
of like all right he knows where to go
he understands the protection
why blitz here let's just double one of
these receivers or take it away because
there's not a lot of options here for
him to go to anyways but it's a good
start for him
what could scare a defense into not
blitzing would be the development of a
receiver who can consistently get
separation or get open and provide that
target and we mentioned jacoby myers
earlier with 12 catches and 169 yards
that's an impressive evening does that
make him into a guy that that becomes
that favorite target that guy who is the
relief valve in the event of a blitz it
may have just been one game it's hard to
tell against the jets defense because
it's not like the jets have a great
defense but the story on the patriots
for the past few years has been they
don't have the receivers who can get
separation and make it easier for a
quarterback who's being blitzed chris to
to to say hey there's my guy who's
running wide open that's always the
danger of the blitz you're letting one
guy yeah be
potentially wide ass open as bruce
arians would say and that doesn't happen
with the patriots no it doesn't and you
know the one guy that they had that
could be that to a degree julian edelman
he's not there i mean he would be the
go-to guy in a lot of those moments last
night
not that it would be you know 50-yard
bombs down the field
but a guy that understands route running
and coverages and oh it's a blitz let me
speed this process up so my quarterback
can hit me all those type of things you
know so they're you know let's not
forget that they are missing him they
are missing stefan gilmore that was a
big part of their football you know
football team as well i mean he is the
defensive mvp
that does hurt them the trickle-down
effect of match-ups in the pass game i
have a hard time believing all those big
pass plays happen for the jets of stefan
gilmours out there last night i do but
you know again
i think the big thing with cam newton
the offense we saw a transition
to
a more pro-style i think new england
finally said wait we can't kill our
quarterback and run them this much and
we just don't have enough players and
offense to run you know the bells and
whistles cam newton offense that i was
trying to say about before with the
speed sweeps and people running
everywhere they don't have the people to
even do that so i think they just said
we got to get in the i formation and
mcdaniels you got to coach them up and
that's the approach they took and then
you know they hung in there and then the
jets
did jets things at the end to make sure
the patriots could win the game
it's almost like the the you know the
original west coast offense that slow
methodical extended drive they didn't
burn anybody over the top and and it's
almost like you're protecting your
defense by keeping them off the field
too and when you look at at what they
did in the second half
that just consistent ability look at
their last five drives yeah they were
all scoring drives uh that goes a long
way toward propping up a defense that
gives up 27 points and and that's
the when you consider
i don't want to say joe flacco's washed
up because he looked anything butt
washed up last night but we would have
thought going into the game that joe
flacco's best days are far in the
rearview mirror and i know he's trying
to re-establish himself similarly cam's
trying to reestablish himself but the
patriots defense just isn't good let's
hear from bill belichick on the team's
past defense without stephon gilmore on
the field
defensively we we didn't play well in
the passing game and just uh
just wasn't wasn't one of our better
performances we had some
good plays where we you know had those
routes covered and then we obviously had
some where we didn't
and just an overall consistency
standpoint we do that
we've got to defend the past and get a
little better we did tonight but
consultant bill emerged a little bit
more from him but he popped out a little
more
um
you know
he he's a master at at defense and you
you could put 11 guys that you just
see at four seasons total landscaping in
philadelphia on the field and
that's a good one
you know
they'll at least eventually figure out
what to do with those guys but uh
um you know that's that's belichick but
still 27 points given up to the jets
it it kind of tells you that if this
team is going to
get to 500 at some point before they run
out of chances to get there
the offense is going to be the reason
not the defense yeah yeah i mean
definitely you know hey the offense
showed a little life last night at least
i mean that's that's the one thing you
can look at hey flacco i was with you
you know i kind of what you said a
minute ago i kind of was going man
flacco he needs to kind of play good
tonight
to if he wants to even be a backup next
year in his career he needed to play
well so that was good for him you know
he he didn't just stand there all night
got out of the pocket made some throws
on the run that's life in the 2020 nfl
you got to be able to do that but hey
with denzel mims and perryman and
crowder first time i think they said all
year right all three were healthy at
least that's as good as i can remember
to to where all right that's respectable
they might be able to create a little
offense now with those three weapons and
flacco did some really good things
but man
i mean it's 27-20 the patriots are
within a touchdown
first play you just drop back and throw
a post into double coverage just drop
back and throw it interception oh guess
what cam newton goes down and scores a
touchdown 27-27
then
to get eight yards on first down and the
subsequent drive and it's second and two
and to take a sack there
i mean that was just unbelievable and
then the of course the incompletion the
play after that to give the patriots the
ball back immediately you know those are
things with joe flacco where you just go
come on man you played too much football
to throw that interception to take that
sack in that moment there and ultimately
what gave new england life to win the
game
quick flacco observation he is one of
the rare
former franchise quarterbacks right he
was the highest paid quarterback in
league history from 2013
until i think aaron rodgers caught him
and then he passed aaron rodgers again
with his renegotiation after three
seasons because the cap numbers were
just ridiculous and he even got more
money than he was getting he's one of
the few right that will continue to hang
around and take a paycheck once he's no
longer a starter usually the true
franchise guys if i'm not the guy i'm
i'm not sticking around for this i don't
need to i got the money i got all the
money i i'm rich as hell as todd gurley
would say
i'm out right so the idea that it's just
it's kind of hey maybe he really loves
football or maybe he's just made some
really bad investments i doubt that
that's it but you don't see franchise
quarterbacks hanging around and hanging
around and hanging around for any scraps
they can get chris no you don't
especially you know like you said with
all that money he's made it's really
rare like really like mike seriously who
who is it who has done that before like
now that you say it off the top of my
head i i
i can't really think of like a true
established franchise quarterback in one
spot for a long time made a lot of deep
playoff runs super bowl whatever
i i you're right mike i can't just
imagine imagine brett favre right
holding the clipboard oh marino yeah
holding a clipboard now flacco was never
quite but he's the guy's a former super
bowl mvp i know so maybe one of the
reasons we don't think of him that way
is here he is holding a clipboard so
i think a lot of that that ego and that
mentality you know randall cunningham is
one of the few great quarterbacks and i
don't know that he you know he had
moments where he was clearly a franchise
quarterback but it wasn't sustained he
collected that four million per year or
whatever the going rate was at the time
as long as he could well what the hell
why not do it all i'm doing is standing
here you know but he never had that
gigantic over the top you know mike vick
is one of the ones yeah who but he had
pulled around as long as you do right
yeah he had life issues and money issues
too i you know i think to where he had
right he did right for those for those
efforts that's where it's weird joe's a
good guy he's very humble he does not
have an ego and he's probably like what
the hell else am i gonna do with my life
for five months a year why don't i just
go you know to practice and throw the
football watch football a little bit and
i think that's really about as much as
he chalks it up to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports